a small community in the Pacific
Northwest a dynamic company is growing
this company has served the equipment
dealer market for 30 years they did it
by following their principles by being
the best and by being honest to their
customers
disis technology driven people focused
[Music]
I think the unique thing about Johnson
Tractor and maybe it isn't unique to us
but our industry is an awful lot of hard
work in the spring and the fall I came
from the banking world and we worked
hard there but this is different the
pace in the spring and the fall is very
hectic we try to do what we can to keep
our customers going and eliminate any
downtime they might have and I see our
employees giving 110 120% during those
times and I think that is
unique they seem tired sometimes but
happy to do it uh it's a it's a
different pace and it isn't for
everybody but we have surrounded
ourselves with an awful lot of good
people who are very committed to their
jobs and I think that's good for us and
it's especially good for our customers
and I think employees have a way of of
working with each other and teaching
each other um they sort of start to
learn and I think we all have what's
acceptable in a workplace and what is
the norm um Leon Eric worked very hard
during the those busy months too and I
think that's an example um we try to be
flexible with our employees as far as we
don't want them to miss family events
and and trying to schedule their time
appropriately so I think they see that
and then are willing to make go the
extra mile when we need them as well um
so I I think they learn from each other
I think we all try to have a team
approach um it's fun to see them problem
solving with a technician and a parts
person and maybe Leo and Eric all
working on something together to get a
farmer going and that's what it's all
about and and I think they enjoy the
[Music]
challenge in a small community in the
Pacific Northwest a dynamic company is
is growing this company has served the
equipment dealer market for 30 years
they did it by following their
principles by being the best and by
being honest to their
customers
dis technology-driven people focused
[Music]